Здавалося б, просто скло - але в нього "зашиті" сонячні елементи батарей.
Дві тисячі таких модулів виготовляє щодня фірма Solarwatt з Дрездена.
Скло лише 2 міліметри завтовшки.
Однак воно екологічніше і міцніше, ніж полімерне покриття.
Уявіть: ви встановили на даху сонячні батареї, а там дме вітер, падає сніг,
щодня вони піддаються впливу багатьох чинників.
Панель поступово прогинається, навіть якщо ви цього не бачите,
і з часом в її структурі з'являються мікротріщини.
Батарея хоч і не ламається, і це не видно неозброєним оком,
але ефективність її роботи зменшується.
А сонячні панелі, вкриті склом, мають прослужити як мінімум 30 років,
не втрачаючи своєї потужності.
Таке ноу-хау підприємство вивело на ринок після свого банкрутства у 2012-му,
аби вижити серед азійських акул бізнесу в сфері сонячних батарей.
Кожен хоче робити погоду на ринку сонячної енергії,
зокрема азіати в останні роки.
Вони конкурують за швидкістю, за обсягами.
Вже не одна компанія, і не лише в Німеччині,
але й по цілому світу стала жертвами такої конкуренції.
Але Solarwatt вдалося знайти власну нішу на цьому ринку.
Окрім модулів, прихованих у склі,
підприємство вже два роки виготовляє модулі з акумуляторами,
які дозволяють накопичувати зайву енергію.
Війну масового виробництва азіатам ми програли.
Тепер настав час енергетичної революції 2.0,
тобто системного застосування нових технологій.
А в тому, що стосується інновацій, ми завжди були на висоті.
Тепер маємо реальний шанс зайняти передові технологічні позиції на світовому ринку.
Ідея полягає в тому, щоб споживачі стали енергетично незалежними,
маючи фотовольтаїку на даху та потужний акумулятор енергії в підвалі.
Тож, ще одне "ноу-хау", за рахунок якого фірма планує захопити передові позиції на ринку,
це "розумні" системи розподілу енергії.
Ці системи показують, скільки ватт надходить з даху,
скільки витрачається у домогосподарстві, скільки накопичується в акумуляторі
і скільки в підсумку надходить в електромережу.
Під час кризи компанії довелося скоротити понад 70% співробітників.
Ставка на інновації дозволила відновити половину втрачених робочих місць.
Навіть попри те, що їхня продукція значно дорожча за китайську.